alors là vous dites n'importe quoi
[Musique]
il y a des gens alors qu'est ce que
c'est votre banderoles abbas a pas bien
marché de alors les confettis lieu d'une
manif et le sang coule de leur masse est
pas si la sec
renseignez-vous bien alors quelqu'un
prend la parole et poudre il faut que ce
soit il faut que vous disiez débat qui
est ce que quelqu'un peut prendre la
parole et expliqué plus tôt côté alors
juste je finis pour vous dire posant une
question et je répondrai à la question
alors là vous dites n'importe quoi ça ne
me paraît pas une question mais une
accusation non ce cas là c'est une
démonstration et la sécurité va s'en
occuper
c'est un lieu de débat monsieur zh mais
venez venez dalo mais cela vous arrivait
pas à temps les messieurs ne sortait pas
et non moi je ne vous dis je ne vous
tutoient nouveau tort quoi que ce soit
je dit juste c'est un lieu de
discussions c'est un lieu de discussions
si vous m'autorisez je réponds à votre
camarade ou collègues
vous pouvez poser votre question et je
répondrai et mettez pas des papiers
partout parce que quelqu'un va le
ramasser 60 pas vous monsieur ne veut
pas poser de questions sur leur
manifester
mais attendez le je vais vous écouter
mais si vous avez de deux ans de respect
monsieur si vous avez un peu de respect
je finis la réponse à votre collègue et
je vous donne la parole
alors monsieur puis là il n'a pas
ramasser les papiers alors monsieur
parce que il a repris un truc que vous
avez dit c'est n'importe quoi les en
france les crs ne s'attaque pas aux
étudiants ou autre il ya pendant des
jours et des jours des étudiants et
beaucoup de nos étudiants si vous vous
renseignez y compris un petit chien qui
avaient un compte twitter extrêmement
sympathique à tolbiac je vous le
recommande le petit chien de tolbiac
kiki qui fait concurrence aux chats du
10 downing street pour les amateurs de
comptes twitter qui ont saccagé
l'université il faut arrêter les bêtises
et la moitié des gens qui étaient dedans
sont pas étudiants depuis longtemps
c'est des groupes anarchistes
malheureusement ils ont arrêté les
études depuis très longtemps ils ont pas
envie de s'y remettre
moi je serais très favorable à ce
qu'elle prenne les études ils ont pas
envie et donc ils ont occupé une
université on les a laissés il ya eu
aucune intervention avec de la violence
contre eux il ya d'ailleurs eu plus de
blé beaucoup de blessés malheureusement
dans nos forces de l'ordre à qui je
rends hommage
elle n'a pas eu leur côté et ils ont été
évacuées et on va dépenser pour nos
universités des centaines de milliers
d'euros pour réparer ce qu'ils ont fait
ce qui est franchement inacceptable on
peut pas défendre le savoir quand on
détruit les universités ensuite nous
avons évacué parce que je pense qu'il
faisait référence à ça des gens à notre
dame des landes comme nous continuerons
à le faire partout y est tu sais pas
vous hein il évoqué ça à notre dame des
anges
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a arrêté le
projet contre lequel il était qui est un
projet qui était plus cohérent sur le
plan écologique mais voulait continuer à
s'installer empêcher les gens de vivre
normalement quand il ya des conflits
d'usagé dans une société il n'y a pas de
liberté s'il ya pas dans le public